Speaker 1: It's great to have back on the
program today, Vincent Racaniello, who's a
virology professor at Columbia University
and also host of This Week in Virology.
Great to have you back.
I really appreciate it.
Speaker 2: Oh, great to be here.
Speaker 1: So I mean, I guess we have to start
with Macron and the if whatever prediction
you want on Macron, you can find it, which
is this is the beginning of something that's
going to get much worse.
This is the beginning of the end of the pandemic
and everything in between.
What do we know now about the level of transmissibility
of Macron in terms of its R value, as well
as how much more or less likely it is to cause
hospitalization?
Speaker 2: So determining transmissibility
is very difficult, so getting of our value,
especially this far into an epidemic, is very
hard.
But I like to look at what we call secondary
attack rates, which are calculated in closed
situation like a household.
Yes, where you can know that this person was
infected and then within a certain amount
of time, these other people got infected.
And it's not easy to do that.
But recently, a preprint came out of Denmark
where they did it, and the beauty of the study
was it was just when they were transitioning
from Delta to Akron.
So you had households that were either in
al-Muqrin household or a Delta household,
it was right.
Perfect, perfect.
And they had good numbers and they have a
terrific medical records registry there so
they could get all the information.
And what was very clear is that AMA crime
has a higher secondary attack rate than Delta,
so it's transmitting better in the household
situation.
But that appears to be entirely due to the
fact that al-Muqrin is evading antibodies
because, as you know, it has many changes
in the spike protein more than any other variant.
And if you take sera from people who have
been vaccinated or recovered from infection,
it doesn't block infection with Macron as
well as, say, with Delta.
And so the Danish scientists concluded that
this increased ability of al-Muqrin to transmit,
say, within households is entirely due to
immune evasion and not to an inherent increased
transmissibility of the virus.
So we imagine that there are some properties
of viruses that can make them transmit better.
Maybe they reproduce better.
They're more stable in droplets that come
out of your respiratory tract.
But that's not the case with Macron.
It really is evading antibodies, and that's
why it's spreading now.
The other part of your question how about
disease right now, with first reports out
of South Africa that it might be milder and
people started to call it an army cold, which
is not really right.
My colleague Daniel Griffin, an infectious
disease doctor, says that's not right because
he's seen plenty of very sick people infected
with Macron and especially unvaccinated people.
So in the unvaccinated, Macron can be just
as severe as Delta and previous variants.
But the South African study was kind of complicated
because a lot of the people in their study
were vaccinated and a lot of them were younger,
and a lot of them didn't have co-morbidities.
And so that old bias is it to be milder.
So, you know, making conclusions very quickly
about how severe infections are is very difficult.
So I would say at this point, we know that
Macron can evade immunity, and that's why
it moves through a population.
Well, it can infect vaccinated people just
like Delta could.
But in a vaccinated person, the disease is
much milder than an unvaccinated person with.
Speaker 1: There's so many things that we
could go off to the from there.
Just a couple.
So if we look at the UK as an example, a layperson
might look at cases and deaths.
And of course, at this point, we know that
not nearly all of the infections are being
captured as a case which depends on a test.
But putting that aside, for a moment, it looked
like during the army, current wave cases went
up about six in the UK known cases, whereas
deaths went up somewhere between 80 and 100
percent or so.
When you see that, it suggests that it is
in some way less likely to kill people and
that's UK, not South Africa.
But are those two numbers alone not enough
to really tell us that?
Speaker 2: Well, the problem is that a lot
of the people are Vaxart are vaccinated, and
if you stratify the data, yes, vaccinated
versus unvaccinated, make sure you control
for age and comorbidities, which is not easy
to do.
True, then you find that in its milder in
vaccinated people, but so is Delta, and so
are all the other variants.
But the fact is that vaccination works.
It prevents you from getting severe disease.
In that part of the issue is with Macron,
it came at about the holiday season, right
when everyone is traveling and getting together.
Plus, we are now getting together way more
than we ever did since the beginning of the
pandemic, because people are starting to relax
and all of this contributes there.
So, you know, movement of a virus has many
factors around it, not just the virus, not
just your immunity, but how people behave
as well.
Speaker 1: The wastewater data in some cities
in the United States is showing just dramatic
reductions in the amount of virus during this
Omicron wave.
I think when I looked 10 days ago or so, or
maybe a week ago at Boston wastewater data,
it was down about two thirds, even though
cases are only down about 10 percent, which
which, you know, you would imagine that that
would be cases would be a lagging indicator
to the wastewater.
How important is the wastewater data?
Speaker 2: I'm not sure you can.
You can quantify anything.
All you can say is we have this virus here
now.
So there may be a period where you don't see
a virus in wastewater or the levels are very
low and then suddenly you get more positive.
So that can inform you of an impending epidemic.
But I would not make much of the levels because,
you know, this is this is incidental virus
that you're swallowing.
It's passing out of your gastrointestinal
tract and going into the sewer.
So.
It's not really part of the infection process.
Mm-Hmm.
So, so to ascribe any meaning to how much
is there?
Remember, it's we're doing PCR to measure
viral RNA in the water.
And as a recent study out of Switzerland just
showed, there is very little correlation between
PCR levels and infectious virus.
So I think you have to be you have to realize
the limitations of looking at virus RNA in
wastewater.
Speaker 1: That's fair.
That's fair.
Last time you were on, we talked a little
bit about the very top level understanding
that we have about viruses over time becoming
less deadly.
And you gave us many caveats when we talked
about that.
But it was this sort of general idea in the
last few weeks as the conversation about what
happens after Macron has become a more and
more relevant conversation.
There have been a bunch of different articles
coming out claiming to debunk that idea as
a general principle that really viruses become
more chaotic and that that could get you a
milder disease, but it might not, and that
there are counterexamples from history.
Can we now because it seems more relevant
than ever?
Talk a little more specifically about this
idea of what is likely to come next after
Macron.
Speaker 2: So the idea, which we talked about
last time, you know, it's a it's a human idea
that viruses over time tend to get less virulent.
But we're talking about long, long periods
of time.
We're not talking about two years here.
So, for example, if a virus spilled, remember
all human viruses came from some other animal
at some point in time.
Let's say thousands of years ago, tens of
thousands of years ago, measles virus 15000
years ago spilled over into people from cows.
Right.
And so initially, it's probably quite lethal
because it's a new host.
We have no immunity to the virus.
And it does what SARS-CoV-2 does.
But over time, population immunity grows,
and that helps you have more a milder disease
when you get infected now.
There's also this hypothesis that maybe the
virus changes over time because there's no
point in killing your host or making your
host very sick.
So random changes in the genome that reduce
virulence may persist.
But I have to say, you know, with the one
exception that we might have talked about
last time using viruses to kill rabbits in
Australia, there's no other evidence that
viruses tend to get less virulent over time,
and their host is just an appealing hypothesis
to the Australian situation.
They had brought in rabbits in the 1800s for
hunting purposes.
They hope they multiplied like crazy.
There were too many of them, so they introduced
a virus to try and kill them.
And in the first year, 99 percent of the rabbits
were killed.
But then those those one percent that survived
were more resistant to the virus, and then
the virus changed to be less virulent as well.
So it's actually a beautiful experiment that's
consistent with this idea.
But I must say there's no other evidence for
it.
And as you mentioned, as soon as al-Muqrin
came out, we had these data from South Africa.
People were saying, Oh, it's getting less
virulent, but I think it's far too premature
to say that because as we've already talked
about, there are lots of confounding factors
there.
Speaker 1: So what does that do for the conversation
about what, what is next and whether we are
months from shifting from the pandemic to
the endemic phase of this?
Is it?
Can we really say anything about that at this
point?
Speaker 2: Well, from the start, we have thought
that as population immunity grew to this virus,
we would have less and less severe disease.
And we see that in vaccinated people.
It supports that even though we have many
variants emerging that can evade immunity
to a certain extent.
The vaccines still work.
They protect you from severe disease and hospitalization,
really in the 90s percent still so.
And we know from other coronaviruses the common
cold coronaviruses that infect all of us every
year that widespread population immunity probably
associates with milder disease.
And so that from the very start led to this
idea that over time, as more of the world
became immune to SARS-CoV-2, we would have
less and less severe disease.
The virus would not necessarily be changing
with respect to virulence, but simply population
immunity would do that.
I really think that's what's going to happen
because we see the vaccines working really
well despite the antigenic evolution of the
virus.
So I've always thought and this was actually
an idea influenced by Ralph Baric, who was
a corona virologist for many years, he said
this will probably be a common cold corona
virus who knows how long it will take.
And at that point, we might not need to vaccinated
it against it any longer.
Speaker 1: We're not at that point yet, though.
Speaker 2: I don't think we are because, you
know, most of the world is still not fully
vaccinated, right?
Right.
There are some countries that have very high
rates of vaccination, and they have much less
disease as a consequence.
But there are other countries like Africa,
which which are barely vaccinated.
So we can't hope to end a pandemic until we
get well, either a lot of people infected
or vaccinated.
I mean, that's what's going to happen now.
Over the next few years, you're going to either
get vaccinated or you're going to get infected.
In both cases, you're going to get some kind
of immunity.
Speaker 1: There are a few countries, at least
a couple, the U.K.
Australia that are pretty quickly going in
a direction of saying, we are.
We believe we are functioning as though we
are in the endemic phase.
We are going to start removing restrictions
and kind of putting this at the individual
level to say if if I have a particular reason
that I need to go beyond what's required of
me by by the state, I'm going to do it based
on my level of risk.
Does that make any sense to you at this point
in time?
Speaker 2: It does, and I've been thinking
about this for now many weeks because we it's
very clear we have multiple vaccines that
work.
They don't prevent infection, which is normal,
but they do prevent severe disease.
And so in many countries like the UK and Israel,
in the U.S., where we have plenty of vaccine,
we now have vaccines that can control severe
disease.
People who have decided not to be vaccinated
have made their choice.
So I think the rest of the population can
now start to move on.
The only problem with that idea is that if
too many unvaccinated people get infected
as you.
The health care system gets overburdened,
yes, and that is a problem because they have
other issues to deal with, they have other
health problems in patients to deal with.
So we don't want hospitals full of unvaccinated,
severely ill COVID patients.
That's why I think in many places in the U.S.,
we're still masking.
Even though we're all fully vaccinated, many
of us are fully vaccinated.
There's no risk to us anymore of getting severely
ill.
We are protecting the unvaccinated,
Speaker 1: the biggest and most regular pushback
that I hear when anybody says what you just
said is, but hold on a second.
Even the people doing everything correctly,
getting their three doses and et cetera, they
are still at greater risk due to the unvaccinated
because of the ability to spread the disease.
The counter that's in increasingly being placed
upon us is, well, hold on a second with Anna
Coren.
It's not clear that the vaccines prevent transmission.
They prevent death, they prevent serious illness.
But but do they really prevent transmission?
So it's really a two part question.
What about the people saying even those who
did the right things?
We are still at risk because of everybody
else.
And number two, what do we know about the
effect of the vaccine on transmission right
now?
Speaker 2: So the I feel I am not at risk
from an unvaccinated person.
OK, I am triple vaccinated, and if I get infected,
which I likely will, I will have a mild disease.
But there's a very good chance I have a mild
disease.
Most of the severe disease in unvaccinated
and vaccinated people, you know that 10 percent
or so that are in people with co-morbidities,
you they're older or they're obese.
That's a big one or a diabetic or asthmatic.
Those are the people who are most likely to
have severe disease, even if fully vaccinated.
Of course, we don't want to forget the kids
under five who can't be vaccinated yet.
We still have to be careful about them.
So I don't view vaccinated people as the ones
at risk.
It's the unvaccinated people, and they're
the ones that are going to cause problems
in the health care system.
Now, with respect to transmission, there was
a wonderful preprint out of Switzerland last
week and this complements other work that's
that's come out as well, which clearly shows
that, well, first of all, you can't measure
transmission by doing PCR.
That is very clear, and almost every study
that has looked at shedding of a vaccinated
person is wrong because they're measuring
PCR, and that does not correlate with infectious
virus shedding in the Swiss study.
They showed that a vaccinated person not only
sheds less infectious virus than an unvaccinated
person, but does so for fewer days after being
infected.
OK, so that has significant implications.
So vaccination doesn't abolish shedding, it
doesn't abolish transmission, but it knocks
it so far down that it no longer plays a role
in driving the epidemic.
So that that
Speaker 1: seems to then support those who
say I'm vaccinated, but the unvaccinated are
putting me at risk.
I know statistically you still won't be seriously
ill, but a lot of people have co-morbidities
in this country.
It sounds like it's not wrong to say, even
as a vaccinated person, the unvaccinated do
put me at greater risk.
Speaker 2: No, the unvaccinated do not, because
you are not going to get sick, right?
If you're fully vaccinated, the likelihood
you're going to get severely ill is very low.
Speaker 1: Oh, I see.
So it's both.
It's both that the by being by being unvaccinated,
you are shedding more virus, by being vaccinated.
You also are less likely to actually get sick.
Speaker 2: Exactly.
OK, but you are less likely to pass it on
to someone else as well.
So the more people we have vaccinated, the
more likely we can stop the transmission.
Speaker 1: That's we are going to link to
that preprint from Switzerland.
It sounds like there's really a wealth of
a wealth worth of data there.
We've been speaking with Vincent Racaniello,
virology professor at Columbia University,
and make sure to check out this week in virology.
Always great having you on.
Speaker 2: Thank you for having me, David.
Appreciate it.